say what does it all mean here's the man
that can tell us our economics and data
editor Ed Conway who's been tracking
this vivently and talk to me about what
today means what's the general picture
let me show you so first of all with
with inflation because actually you know
we're talking a moment ago about the
kind of breakdown of different parts of
inflation and why it matters and this is
quite a good way of looking at it so
this this is the rate of inflation of
course the higher that that is the
higher costs are increasing you know on
an annual basis that's what inflation is
it's the you know the cost of living and
that's that's been going up really fast
what's interesting is when you kind of
break that down and look at the
different parts the different components
of what is driving up inflation because
this it's basically a shopping basket
and here we've broken down the shopping
basket so you can see all of this stuff
is things like household bills household
goods transport and what you can
probably see is look that was enormous
it was by far and away the biggest part
of inflation pushing up the overall
number for a long time but look at how
that started to get a lot smaller in the
last few months but the issue issue is
so I'll get kind of rid of that bit the
issue is this stuff it's the other stuff
that's been building up and up and up
and up and that's what's worrying you
know the bank of England's boiling
economists
um because that looks I guess stickier
and that has kind of implications
elsewhere as well still looks like it's
on the up um should we talk about
interest rates because of course that's
something that everybody watches out for
that announcement the bank of England
due to make another one next month
exactly what does it mean for interest
rates and that's the kind this is the
kind of thing they're looking at and
saying Oh Hang on we're quite worried
about that because core inflation the
underlying rate of inflation stripping
out all that volatile stuff that's good
that kind of unnerves them and and on
interest rates I mean actually in a way
this this might be the story of the day
really not just the inflation numbers
but what's happening here and it's worth
just saying you know obviously it's good
news that inflation is coming down we
don't discount that at all and that
degree at which the acceleration of the
cost of living crisis is is starting to
diminish but it's still very tough for
many households and this this kind of
adds to it and this is the worry so last
week this is where kind of people in the
market so Traders thought interest rates
was going to go this is kind of where we
are at the moment four and a half
percent they thought it might Peak
around 4.75 percent uh towards the end
of this year and then kind of come
gradually down so a little bit higher a
little bit tougher for mortgage holders
but then came that news just this
morning on inflation and just look at
what happened to that so look at the
latest curve the latest expectations for
interest rates and they are
significantly higher and I know that you
know in the scheme of what we
experienced last year with the mini
budget and the crazy stuff on on
interest rates you know we all remember
that
but that is a really big move in you
know in one day or indeed a few days on
interest rate expectations and that
means that people you know that those
rates 5.5 that's not to be sniffed at
and it's worth just saying actually I I
know you're going to ask that kind of
because a lot of people wandering off
five and a half percent it doesn't sound
like that much in comparison with the
years ago yeah what we saw in 1980s
1990s well this kind of one this is
quite an important Point as well so yeah
if you look just at the official bank
rate this is going all the way back to
the 60s just so we can make that point
and yeah it's certainly true that that's
rates at 4.5 that's rates at 5.5 even at
five and a half percent it's the highest
since 2008 okay well that's high but
it's not necessarily anything like what
you saw over here look kind of 14 15 or
so
but here's the thing back then people
didn't have quite as big mortgages quite
as much debt as they do now back then
they had slightly higher incomes in
relation to their mortgage repayments
than they do now and when you kind of
adjust for that so adjusting for the
higher debt load adjusting for all of
these other factors you get a kind of
different line here this red line and
this is the one that I want to focus on
here okay so I'm going to just kind of
Zoom onto that red line and it's the
same thing but we're just kind of like
zooming into it this is that same thing
interest rates adjusted for repayment
pressures okay and that's kind of where
we are where we are not long ago
um that is 4.5 percent
the highest since 2005 okay so so pretty
high if you get up to 5.5 percent
just look 5.5 when you adjust for all of
those changes in the nature of our
mortgages that's the highest that we've
seen since 1991 since this enormous
Spike which was the kind of post-lawson
mortgage crunch yeah that that was
basically what contributed to the worst
housing crash we've ever seen in this
country and we are we're not there but
we're kind of heading up into that realm
and that's that's a worry so five and a
half percent interest this is the key
thing five and a half percent interest
rates which is what the market now
expects after those inflation numbers
our equivalent to interest rates in the
double digits back in that in our old
world when people didn't have as big
mortgages
and that really matters and that's kind
of where according to these later latest
data we're heading so this this really
is the big story today good news that
inflation's in double no longer double
digit very bad news that it's stickier
than expected with the implication that
the bank of England might now be looking
at interest rates five and a half
percent the highest that we've seen
since 1991 when you adjust for all of
that stuff